Salut c'est Jean Jacques Goldman!
Fake ou réalité ?
Aujourd'Hui je vais Faire Un Chalenge
Si c'est Un Fake or Real
"Real or Fake"
C'est le jeu au quel nous allons (pas) jouer aujourd'hui.
"Le jeu te montrera 15 photos."
"Certaines sont des originaux, et d'autres ont été retouchées, éditées"
"ou, PHOTOSHOPÉES" (c'est pas Français mais bon)
Comme cette homme aux abdos divins! (que tu n'auras pas)
"Pour chaque photos cliques sur le bouton approprié pour soumettre ta réponse."
"Si la photo est un fake, le jeu te montrera la photo AVANT qu'elle ai été photoshopée."
"Combien de bonne réponse peut-tu faire ?"
Ooooookayyy
Est-ce que toutes ces heures a s'être perdu sur Internet,
Vont nous servir ?
C'est la question que je me pose à chaque fois qu'j'vois 4 heures et demie sur Spion.
Première photo. C'est partie on commence.
Baaaaaaaaaah.
Ça m'a l'air vrai. Mais,
ça fait vraiment cette taille ?
Est-ce qu'en vrai, la photo du reptile n'est pas carrément, euh, en plus gros plan ?
Et on l'a détourée pour le mettre sur un doigt au gros plan ?
Mec, ça fait pas cette taille ! Mais c'est totalement photoshopée !
QUOI ?!
Naaaan ! *rire*
Mais le truc fait cette taille vieux.
Donc c'était une sorte de caméléon
On va pas se mentir.
"Les caméléons sont des petits reptiles de taille modérée : les plus petites espèces font près de 3 cm de long."
*silence*
Ah m*rde !
Mais j'étais persuadé que c'était... Minimum ça !
AH M*RDE !
C'est pas grave on panique pas, il nous reste...
La photo des vaches.
Bon mec, ça a pas l'air photoshopée.
Je vois pas, l'intérêt de photoshoper ça ! En vrai.
Tu vas dans le champ à côté de chez toi, tu prends une photo, y a ça.
Et t'as pas... Nan c'est la vérité !
*silence*
Quoi ?!
Mais attends...
Le mec il rajoute une vache sur une photo où y a des vaches déjà.
On part mal. On part très mal.
Ça c'est photoshopé ça ? Pourquoi Est-ce que cet aigle serait... Attends, attends, 'tends.
*Il recherche sur Google* Aigle. *rire*
On va regarder, euuh, les aigles !
Ben non je vois pas en quoi c'est photoshopée, c'est juste un aigle debout sur une branche !
C'est vrai !
Oh p*tain ! Vous voyez je me mets la pression pour rien maintenant !
Je vois un truc parfaitement normal, je crois que c'est un fake !
C'est juste des montagnes. Qu'est-ce que quelqu'un aurait pus photoshoper. L'eau ?
Il aurait pu lui rajouter la montagne ? En vrai y a pas cette grosse montagne là tu penses ?
Ben non.
J'suis sûr qu'en fait ce gros bloc n'est pas là sur la photo originale.
Bon on va dire vrai ?
Oh oui c'est bon ! Putain on se met la pression pour rien !
Ouf ! Un ours blanc qui a chassé le poisson.
Le poisson a l'air en bon état.
Comme quand tu l'achètes au Casino à côté de chez toi.
COMMENT cet ours aurait pu choppé le poisson, sans l'abimer ?
Parce que on dirait pas mais ce truc a des griffes comme ça mon gars !
Fake.
Et bim ! Voilà y avait pas de poisson à la base !
BOOM ! Boom !
Alors. Ouuuuuuuuuuuuuh...
Un avion, qui passe, SOUS le Golden Gate.
On dirait que l'avion a été pris en photo sous un certain angle de vue !
Et que le pont a été pris en photo sous un AUTRE angle de vue !
Donc quand tu mets les deux ensemble ... *tu tu tu tu tu*
Vous ne m'aurez pas.
Après, y a forcément un mec qui est passé en avion sous le Golden Gate un jour.
Roh, c'est terrible !
C'est tellement un truc de ouf c'que l'mec fait dans l'avion que ils veulent te faire croire que c'est du fake.
Ils veulent que tu n'y croient pas, mais en vrai, Est-ce que ce n'est pas juste la vérité ?
Ah nan.
Nan. Y avait vraiment pas l'avion ! Je savais que cette photo était bizarre !
C'est carrément une chouette.
Pourquoi ils auraient photoshopée ?
Ah d'accord. Le gars il avait pas d'idées ! *rire*
Ah ça ! Y a moyen que ce soit photoshopée !
Vous savez, les photos d'animaux.
Les mecs sont payés pour que la photo soit la plus belle possible ! Donc c'est possible qu'il ai pris, ces espèces de trucs jaunes là !
Et qu'il les ai multipliés ! Pour une belle harmonisation de la photo !
Donc on va dire Fake.
Pfeu, j'me prends la tête pour rien. *rire*
J'suis mauvais ! On est à 50% ça va, ça va !
Oh le mec il aurait réussis à prendre la photo au bon moment
D'une p*tain d'baleine avec une mouette !
C'est un fake. C'est un fake.
Voiiiilà ! La mouette n'était pas là ! La mouette n'était pas là !
Oh ! Ben ça on dirait un Face Swap entre deux chiens.
C'est même pas la même oreille mais c'est totalement photoshopée !
QUOI ?!
Nani ? ("Quoi" en japonais)
Nan mais mec il était incroyable ce chien ! Mais ça c'est des scientifique qui l'ont crée en laboratoire c'est pas possible mec !
Mais attends on dirait carrément cette photo là, mais qui a été photoshopée !
La photo du Quiz.
Est-ce que le Quiz n'est pas en train de me prendre pour un c*n ?
Donc, ceci est une cathédrale.
Ou une église.
Pourquoi Est-ce que ça aurait été photoshop- qu'Est-ce qui aurait été photoshopée là dedans ?
Je pense c'est du fake...
OUI !
Voilà on a plus eu de chances qu'au BAC.
OK on est à 6 sur 11
Le porc, le porc. Est-ce que le porc est un faux porc ?
Nan nan mais non mais mec la j'suis en train de perdre du temps pour rien !
Voilà c'est juste une photo d'un PORC ! P*tain il faut arrêtez les c*nneries !
Alors ça par contre c'est Photoshop ! L'éclair, il était pas là ! La route elle était pas... Allez hop fake !
Voilà, BIM !
Ah y faisait pas nuit ! C'est ça l'astuce !
Pour faire des belle photos de nuit faut faire des belles photos de jour !
Et d'ouvrir Photoshop.exe ... Ok.
Alors là, j'pense qu'y a un délire avec les nuages !
Que soit y avait des nuages avants ils les ont retirés, soit ils ont rajoutés un nuage ou deux...
Si ils ont photoshopée c'est que le ciel était tout bleu, ou que y avait trop de nuages.
Mais ça me paraît quand même euuh... J'pense c'est une vrai.
P*tain... Le ciel était tout bleu.
Le ciel était tout bleu ! Je le dis pourquoi je ne m'écoute pas !
Qu'est-ce qui fait ce p*tain d'Racoon ?
Nan ça c'est vrai. Non alors la par contre, si je puis me permettre,
Si c'est pas une vraie photo, je ferme ma chaîne YouTube.
Pour le plus grand malheurs des HATERS.
"Game Over". 9 sur 15. 60%.
Ben écouter faites le ! Et puis on compare. Voilà.
Sauf que vu que vous avez vu la vidéo maintenant, ben vous ferais 100% donc ça comptes pas voilà.
Et voilà les gens c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo sur "Fake ou Réalité"
N'hésiter pas de l'aimer si elle vous a plus ! Mais je trouve ça ouf, d'arriver à en fait, de devenir complétement parano en fait.
On a tellement vu de fake et de trucs barrés sur Internet que maintenant on a beaucoup de mal à croire même au trucs les plus vrai !
P*tain, on peut plus avoir confiance en personne.
2016 c'est terrible !
Bon j'espère qu'a la suite de ce jeu, j'arriverais mieux à différencier les photos fake des photos pas fake !
Surtout sur Tinder.
ÉNORME BLAGUE.
Allez à plus dans une prochaine vidéo, merci d'avoir regardé, portez vous bien, ciao tout le monde...
PEACE !
Fake ou Réalité ?
*claques des doigts* GROS FAKE.
(Désolé pour les fautes d'orthographes présentes dans les sous-titre de la vidéo) :)